[APPLAUSE]
LAMA TSOMO: Well, I'm
excited to be here.
Google's pretty famous.
And I never expected to
even end up here at all.
And to be able to share my
favorite things with you guys
is just such an
honor and pleasure.
And, of course, I've shared
the benefits of Google,
as has just about everybody
all across the planet,
so kind of a nice cycle
that I get to partake in.
Hopefully there will be some
benefit both from the book
and from the talk today.
So everybody has
come from busy lives,
whether you're viewing
the video or actually
sitting in person
right now, and so I'd
like for everybody to just stop
and take a moment to be quiet.
We so rarely do it
even for a moment.
So while you're
sitting here you might
think you're doing nothing.
I would say there are a
couple of things you're doing.
One thing is, you're
paying attention, perhaps
to this lady talking.
And there's something
else you're doing,
and you do it all the time.
You hardly ever notice
you're doing it.
You even do it when
you're sleeping.
So as you might have
guessed, you're breathing.
But we're so busy with all
kinds of other things we're
paying attention to out there
that we don't pay attention
to something so
simple and present
as the breathing
going on in here.
So I ask you just
to take a moment
and pay attention to this
breathing that you're doing.
And not saying, I am breathing,
but just the experience
of the belly moving as it moves.
Or maybe you pay
attention and notice
the coolness in your nostrils
and mouth as the air moves.
Congratulations.
You were just meditating.
[CHUCKLES] It doesn't have to
be some big, mystical thing.
For a long time, early on
in my efforts to meditate,
I had all these ideas about what
meditation was supposed to be.
So I thought it was maybe
some kind of hypnotic state,
or I thought I was
supposed to stop my brain.
And the brain is a
thinking machine.
It manages, it handles thoughts.
And it turns out, those things
were totally inaccurate.
But I didn't get a chance to
have meditation instruction
for a long time, so
I kept sort of having
these many misconceptions
and thinking,
I'm a terrible meditator.
Which, by the way, saying
that mantra to yourself
is not conducive to meditation.
I've proven this.
I've proven a lot of ways
not to meditate, by the way.
So another thing
I proved was what
happens when I don't meditate.
Though because I finally got so
discouraged, because I thought,
I'm just not meditating well.
I'm not cut out for this.
My mind wanders
all over the place,
I generate lots of thoughts,
I'm just a terrible meditator.
I'm wasting my time.
Forget it.
So I stopped even trying
to do daily meditation.
And I didn't notice
it right away,
but actually my life started
to get more and more off-track.
And after five years of
doing my personal experiment
in not meditating,
I found myself
really off-track in my
life, not doing the things
that really meant something to
me and that were right for me
in my life.
And it happened by little,
tiny decision after decision.
And we make thousands of
those every day, actually.
And they go by in a flash
and we don't even realize it.
So not coming to
myself every day
and always having the lens
turned outward, never turning
it inward and just kind of
taking a break on responding
to outside things, it turned
out that, even though I
was doing a bad job of it
with just sitting with myself
and just being
quiet, I wasn't there
then when that little
knowing would bubble up.
So what I always think of
is like the eight ball.
You know that thing
where you turn it up
and this little
thing bubbles up?
So, I wasn't there to see it.
But my deepest self, my true
self knew what was right
for me, what was on track
for me, and what wasn't.
And I just wasn't
there to hear it.
So I kind of woke up
to things five years
after not meditating,
you know, beginning
my non-meditation
program, and I realized
I was living in the
place that wasn't right
for me, with people that
were not right for me,
doing stuff that wasn't
right for me, on and on.
And somehow I guess my inner
self just kind of broke
through the distraction
and I was able to hear it.
So I thought, oh my gosh,
even my pathetic attempts
at meditation at least I
was there to hear more.
So I want to meditate every day.
And you know, just kind
of through those thousands
of little decisions,
a little more track.
Hopefully more
and more on track.
But this time I want
to get instruction.
So as a kid I played piano.
And I got much better
at piano for having
gone to a piano teacher.
It turns out, it really helps
to go to a piano teacher,
and practice.
So I thought, maybe the same
principle works for meditation.
So I set about trying to find
a teacher who was right for me,
and I made a list of
the qualities I wanted.
They had to be really
highly-realized,
highly-accomplished
meditator, really
knowledgeable in their
tradition and so on.
And one thing I forgot
to put on the list was,
must speak English.
So he still doesn't
speak English.
He's a Tibetan Lama.
And so I ended up having
to learn Tibetan just
to be able to converse with him.
And it's a very difficult
language to learn.
But it turns out, the same
principles are at work.
You can do it a few
minutes every day,
but it has to be every day.
And sometimes having total
immersion is very important.
And that turns out also to
be true with meditation.
And total immersion in
the Buddhist tradition
is called retreat.
So I did both daily
meditation and retreats
and studied with this Lama.
And he really took me on.
And I would try one practice
and it was so beneficial,
I was feeling so much
better and able to handle
the challenges of life better,
and even in the moment of life
for having been consistently
meditating and doing
these retreats, I got more
and more excited about it
and I wanted to do the next
practice and the next one.
And one thing led to another
and, as my kids put it,
I was lama-nated.
So I am now a Lama myself.
But not on the
level of my teacher.
I still take from him.
But I have certainly
learned a lot.
And I've had a chance to teach
a lot and work with Westerners,
and that's been really
rewarding work for me.
So I've been more and
more on track for me.
And so what you've
probably heard a lot about
is the benefits of
meditation for longevity,
the immune system,
working better.
You can even multitask
better because it turns out
that your brain is actually--
your conscious mind is only
paying attention to
one thing at a time,
but it's shuttling very quickly.
And it appears to us
that we're multitasking,
but actually were shuttling.
And meditation--
in fact, the one
that I'm going to
be teaching you more
formally in a little
bit, and you already
started to do-- that
helps with multitasking.
So there are all kinds of
wonderful studies coming out.
Pain-- helping a great
deal with pain, compassion,
all kinds of benefits.
What I wanted to talk about
and focus more on today
was living in meaningful life.
And they've only just started
doing a lot of studies on that.
There's one 50-year
study that was
done in a book called "Why Good
Things Happen to Good People."
And that's a very
interesting study.
But what I really
want to focus on
is more my understanding
from the Buddhist side of it,
why is it that we all want
to live a meaningful life?
And why is it that so often
a meaningful life involves
somehow benefiting others?
We can just take a
little vote here.
How many people here feel
that a meaningful life to them
would be somehow, in some
way benefiting others?
OK.
It's unanimous.
We have passed by a
unanimous measure.
This is what I always
find to be the case.
Why is that?
Why wouldn't it
be something else?
And even in the
studies on the brain,
what makes us happier for
longer is helping somebody else.
So I'll give you a
Buddhist metaphor.
Let's say that we are
all from one source,
that everything is
created from one source.
And the physicist
David Bohm would
agree with this, that if you
sort of break it all down
and you went into subatomic
physics-- in the early days
it was subatomic physics--
and if we get down
to that level, then
the inside of my skin
and the outside of my skin--
it doesn't look any different.
So we can kind of get down
to a common denominator.
So if that root is a
common denominator,
let's use the
metaphor of an ocean.
So there's one great
big, vast ocean,
and it makes all these different
waves, and each wave is unique.
There are no two that
are exactly alike,
and you can't freeze a wave.
They just keep
changing and moving,
and their shape
changes and so on.
But the important thing
that I'm focusing on
is the uniqueness of all
the waves and the fact
that they're actually
all connected
and part of this one big ocean.
So each of us is a wave,
and yet we're all connected.
So why else would
it be that when
we see a suffering stray
puppy, our heart is moved
and we suffer with
them a little bit?
Now, most of the time
we're too distracted,
but I believe that somebody
who is really accomplished,
somebody like His
Holiness the Dalai Lama--
the cover boy for
my book-- he can
feel a huge amount of suffering
on a much more vast level,
and really suffers with.
So naturally then we're inspired
to do something about that.
And I've noticed that,
for example, people
who have survived
rape really want
to work in the field of helping
others who have survived rape.
Or I was listening
recently to somebody
whose son was killed
by gang violence
and he had to go on this
deep journey of forgiveness,
got to know the family
of the killer of his son,
got to know the
killer of his son,
and became good friends
with the grandfather
of the one who killed his son.
And now the families
have become very close.
And he does presentations
along with the grandfather.
You work with gang
members and work
with families who've lost people
from gang violence and so on,
and he said he's leading
the most satisfying life he
could possibly imagine.
Of course he misses his son, but
this is a way that he could--
it set him on what I
call a redemption story.
And I think we all have
something like that.
And somehow we've-- I know
somebody else who spent seven
years in a very poor
place-- I'm sorry,
a year in a very poor
place when she was seven,
and she was so moved and felt
such pain that she had a roof
over her head and food to eat
and they didn't, it set her
on a path of helping
bring benefit to everyone.
And she's still following
that today in her 50s.
So how do we pursue a
life that's meaningful?
We want our lives to
count for something.
And whatever our unique
gifts are as this wave,
we want to bring that to all of
the ocean and benefit somehow.
How do we find that?
How do we stay on
track day to day?
This is where meditation
can be so helpful.
And this is really what
I'm more focusing on,
rather than all of the
other wonderful things
you've probably read
about in studies.
So how does that work?
A couple of things.
There are many things
I could point to,
but we don't have a lot of time.
So one thing I can point
to is, when you sit quietly
and you're not responding
to the stuff on the outside,
you're taking a break,
and even the stuff
that you normally have to think
about and plan about regarding
your work-- and I think that's
true for a lot of people here.
You know, it's mental work
that you're doing a lot--
to take a break from that.
First of all, I have
a lot of mental work.
Writing books, teaching,
that kind of thing,
working with our
retreat facility
that we're building and so on.
But taking a break
from it and saying,
I don't have to think
about that right now.
I have a few minutes where I'm
going to take a real vacation.
So you can take
a daily vacation.
Every day, but a real one.
Not spending a bunch of
money to go to a beach
or have drinks with
parasols or whatever
and then still your mind is
churning, but a real vacation.
And when you do
that it's like you
get to look into a pond that
normally is all stirred up,
and there's silt all
through the water
and the waves are
churning around,
and you let that all settle.
And the silt settles.
And the waves
settle a little bit.
It doesn't have to be
perfect, but we can see more
what the water really is and
what it looks like all the way
to the bottom.
That's what we can
do for ourselves
in just a few minutes a day.
The key is to do it every day.
I learned this with
practicing piano,
and I learned it with
learning Tibetan.
it's about doing it every day,
even if only for a few minutes.
And you will make progress.
There's a handout that shows the
different stages the brain goes
through in the process of
forgetting and remembering,
because what you find you
do over and over again
in meditation-- I'm going to
make this prediction right
now with confidence-- you're
going to come to this moment
where you go, oh yeah,
I was meditating.
Because what you
were doing instead
was spinning a
movie in your mind.
So thoughts come and go.
And we can just sit and let
the thoughts come and go
as we focus on an
object of support,
like focusing on the breath.
But there's going to
come a moment where
we forget to do that and we
start following after a thought
and making a story, which
is what we-- we all tend
to do that, as human beings.
And it's the making a story
and making this whole movie
and this continuum that is
now no longer meditation.
Just having the thought come
and go while you stay present
and you've just
watched it come and go
and you didn't go after it,
you're still meditating.
That's eligible for meditation.
But as soon as you've
followed after the movie
and then you say, oh,
yeah, I was meditating.
So particular parts
of the brain light up
and it's in the handout
which you're welcome to.
And so these are desirable
parts of the brain that normally
don't light up so much.
We follow after a lot
of thought and make
a lot of movies all day.
So that's already a good thing.
But there's a couple more.
So after we've remembered,
oh yeah, I was meditating,
we bring our mind back to
the object of meditation,
other parts of the brain
light up, also very good.
And then we attempt to keep our
mind there as long as we can.
That lights up yet other
desirable parts of the brain.
And then we forget
again and so it goes.
So that's a wonderful cycle
that Dan Harris calls--
you know, the news anchor.
I don't know if you're
familiar with him.
He wrote a book on his
stumbling into meditation.
It's called "10% Happier."
He refers to this cycle as
bicep curls for the brain.
So it's just fine to
forget and remember,
because then you
get to do all that
and rest freshly in this
peaceful, abiding meditation
called Samatha.
So what is my
offering to the world?
I just want to share that
a little bit with you.
In my adventure not
meditating and then
meditating and discovering it
was so much better when I did,
and I felt so much happier just
ongoing, and so much better
able to handle
challenges in life.
I thought, well, I want
to share this with others,
and I don't want them to have to
wait until they're middle-aged,
they stumble upon a Lama,
they learn to Tibetan,
they sit in retreat in Nepal
and on a mountain in Montana,
you know, for years at a time.
Cumulatively I've spent
years in meditation retreat.
I want to make it easy for
Westerners to get started
and to pursue a path where
they can deepen as much as they
want to all the way to the end.
Or at least just be able
to pursue daily meditation
and have the support for that.
So I began offering
a weekly class
and I noticed that
really I needed
to give more background where
they could just kind of refer
to it on their own.
I thought, I've got
to assign a book.
And also then they don't have to
keep asking the same questions
because this is so new, they
can just refer to the book.
Well, I just looked
and looked and I
couldn't find the book
I was looking for,
so I thought, well,
I'll just write it.
That turned out to
be a big project.
And it grew and grew and grew.
And now this book is one
of a series of three,
and it's already,
you know, pretty big.
But this is the
introductory one.
And it's assuming absolutely
no prior knowledge.
And in the back of the book
there are practiced cards.
So when you want
to remember, OK,
how do I-- what's the
step-by-step and just
a few quick notes,
you can have it right
there wherever it is that you
normally sit and meditate.
And I also wanted to have more
support than just the book,
because once I realized I was
going to put this book out
in the world and not just have
it in a Montana meditation
group, I thought, well,
people need their groups.
People need to sit together and
chew on this stuff together.
And how does this
affect my life?
How does my life
affect my meditation?
How do I put these
things together?
And for people to be able
to chew on that together--
I've seen how rich that is
and how deeply people connect
when they have
something to really sink
their teeth into like that.
How often do we do that?
You know, going
to a bar you don't
have quite the same
quality of conversation.
So I just suddenly thought,
what if the crew on "How
I Met Your Mother" had set aside
a weekly time in somebody's
living room and just talked
about this stuff and, you know,
road-tested these methods
and talked about their lives
together in a meaningful way?
And I give context pieces,
too, and then people
could chew on that.
And so we called these
learning circles.
And we've just
begun setting things
up so that you can fairly easily
get started with a learning
circle.
So you can download a tool kit.
And really, all
the way through, we
see it's terribly important
how the group relates
to each other,
what are the norms.
And now I'm getting into
a "New York Times" article
I read about something
called Aristotle, which
I think you guys know about.
And I was excited to see
that because that's something
I feel strongly about
and I wanted to be sure
that we covered the meditation
instruction, the background,
sort of the map-- how
does this all work, what
is the context, and
so on-- and also
how can we enact these
things in relationship
to each other in these
small groups that
are sort of where the rubber
hits the road and even
in larger groups?
So I enlisted the help of
my friend Aaron Stern, who's
sitting right here, because he's
an expert at that third piece,
the interrelationships
and how to sort
of enact Buddhism in
relationship with each other.
Because he is an expert
at that, has developed
some wonderful methods.
So we're bringing in some
modern Western methods
to add to these time-tested
ones from the East.
And so it's a very
rich combination
that we wanted to offer.
I also am really interested in
mixes of ages working together
because there's-- if you think
back to what we evolved with,
we evolved in villages and
everybody was mixed together.
We weren't separated in classes,
sort of Henry Ford-style
assembly line learning,
which I think is not natural,
not a way to go, and
I think that's why
there's a lot of terrible social
dynamics going on in schools.
And then that's our learning
ground for social dynamics.
But there can be a richness
in mixing ages together
because people in
their young adult years
have a lot of energy and vision.
They know what's coming
just over the horizon.
And there's a power in that.
There's a particular
power in that.
Then for old people like me,
we've been around a long time
and so we've learned
some techniques,
educated ourselves
in some things,
and just spent a lot of
time experiencing life.
And so I think this can be
a very powerful combination.
But again, we need to know how
to work together, and want to.
But I think that's what
were designed to do.
And at this time in
the world we all need
to get together and bring all
of our superpowers together.
Our individual
ones as unique ways
and our different
demographics, all of it
to come together to solve
the very big challenges
of this time.
I think we're ready for
some question and answer,
and then I will more formally
teach you Samatha practice
to finish up the session.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you very much.
I have so many questions.
I was writing ferociously.
LAMA TSOMO: Your page
is full of writing.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I know.
It's really cathartic
to write by hand
and not be typing for once.
I need to take a few
notes back to my desk.
So you just touched on this
at the-- sort of the end
with project Aristotle.
And I think we're
fortunate enough
to work at a place that
supports developing
a practice of mindfulness
through things like gPause
and Search Inside Yourself and
having beautiful meditation
rooms.
But it still is very much
an individual process.
It's very much an
individual journey,
unless you're lucky
enough to find a teacher.
And the general rule of thumb
at Google is, is don't be evil
or don't be a jerk.
You know?
Nobody wants to work
with that person.
But I'm wondering
what your thoughts
are on bridging the gap between
sort of this individual, really
difficult, deep-rooted
practice and then bringing it
to the workplace and
not necessarily taking
your whole team to the
meditation room to meditate,
but how can we benefit and
how can our teams benefit
from the work that we're
doing individually?
LAMA TSOMO: Mm-hm.
So at Namchak we do have a
meditation room also, and at
lunchtime people-- whoever
wants to-- can go in there
and sit and meditate.
So there's that.
But as you said,
what about that gap?
So I don't think you need to
have your work groups also
be your meditation groups.
I think those who are interested
could find each other.
I bet you have
technology for this--
where those who are interested
could find each other.
And I think a good size is,
like, six to eight people.
And if it's more than that there
could be more groups, you know?
There could be lots of groups.
I don't know how many people
you have working at Google,
but there could be many,
many of these groups.
And they can sit in somebody's
office or a little nook
in the cafeteria, whatever.
And just decide, you
know, one a week,
Wednesdays for
lunch or after work
or whatever it is, we're
going to sit together
and we're going to do
the 8-week online course.
We have an online course and
they're weekly installments,
and so people could
do that together,
which would be really fun.
Or work their way through
the book, or both because,
not surprisingly,
since I designed both,
they're very similar.
Basically covering
the same material.
But the book gives
you more background.
It's got more richness to it.
And so it's a good thing to
refer to at least on your own.
And if you guys do set
up learning circles,
at least for the next little
while every time I come back
to California what I'd like to
do is sit with learning circles
and talk with people about,
what's your experience?
How is it going on the cushion?
How is it going in the group?
And that kind of thing.
The other thing is, I have
convinced my friend Aaron
to put together a
Saturday workshop
for working on personal
leadership, group dynamics.
Again, rubber hitting the road
in interpersonal communication
in groups.
And so that might
be something that
learning circle
people would like
and people in just
your work groups
might also enjoy attending that.
So those are some
ways to get started.
And, by the way, there are
teaching videos on the website
so that you can get
talked through--
and also audio-- talked
through the meditations.
And again, meditation cards
in the back of the book.
So those are some ways to get
started not just individually
but also in groups.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And, you know,
based on your experience--
obviously now you're immersed
in a community of Namchak that
is a team of people
who are obviously
very passionate about this
and dedicated to this.
But sometimes we
might be working
with people who have no
interest in mindfulness.
And we all encounter
people in our daily lives
who don't necessarily
find value in that.
So how can you bridge
the gap between someone
who is dedicated to that
and works towards that
and might have a
practice, and someone who
is just at a different point?
I guess, have you
seen ways in which
your communication
and your ability
to work with people of
different backgrounds
has benefited you through
your meditation practice?
LAMA TSOMO: Actually,
at Namchak, we
don't just have meditators.
We also have people
who have no interest
whatsoever in meditation.
We have the whole spectrum.
We have people who
are totally gung-ho
and people who are
never going to do that,
practicing Christians.
And, by the way,
I've taught people
who are practicing
Christians who
wanted to learn how to
meditate and use it every day,
and they're still really
practicing Christians.
So there's a whole gamut.
And we all really
enjoy working together.
And we have invited Aaron
to come and teach us
some of his tools
that he's developed
and work with us and so on.
And we've been able to
then work together happily.
That answers your
question a little bit?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
I had a question a
little earlier on.
One of the first things
you said is, you realized,
I'm not a good meditator.
I'm not good at this.
And my assumption would be
that most people in this room
are somewhat interested
or familiar with
or have a meditation practice.
And there are so many times
when I've experienced this,
"I'm not a good
meditator" moment.
And you mentioned the value
of just sitting and letting
the water settle, even if it's
only settling a little bit,
and seeing what the water is
and what's inside the water.
But what if that doesn't happen?
LAMA TSOMO: Well, I thought
it wasn't happening.
And that's why I stopped.
And it was only in retrospect
that I realized, wait a minute,
it was happening more
than I thought it was.
I think we Westerners have kind
of a low opinion of ourselves,
and it's rather unjustified.
At one point it kind
have occurred to me--
and this is before
my Buddhist days--
I was like, if everything
is made of God, then so
is everybody, including me.
So that's what we're
really made of,
is something that's very pure,
whatever we want to call it.
You know, whatever that source
is, that's our source, too.
And so maybe we're not
so terrible after all.
But there's a funny story I love
to tell about Mingyur Rinpoche.
He's another Lama who-- the
Lamas coming from the East
were confused by
this Western penchant
for kicking ourselves and
thinking we're terrible
and, "I'm not worthy"
and this kind of thing.
Having no compassion
or love for ourselves.
And then, what basis
then do we have
for having compassion and
love for everybody else?
Love thy neighbor as thyself,
even is in the Bible.
So then maybe that's
why America falls
so short of our aspirations to
be a compassionate and loving
country.
But anyway, Mingyur
Rinpoche really
was trying to understand
his American students,
and he finally decided to do
this unworthiness meditation.
And so he practiced
it every day.
And eventually, after
a couple of weeks
of assiduously practicing this,
he was feeling kind of crummy.
And it just got kind
of worse and worse
and then he finally
realized one day,
I feel terrible about myself.
Isn't this great?
Now I understand my
Western students.
He was so happy.
And of course, he was able to
reverse it with the practices
that he knew and was able
to really help his students.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I have one
question before you guide us
through a meditation.
LAMA TSOMO: OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And one of the
first things we did together
was just breathe.
That's It.
Just pause and breathe.
And almost any time I do
this I think and realize
how shallow my breath is.
And it's even shallow
when I'm noticing it.
So imagine when I'm
just at my computer
or in a meeting how
shallow it must be.
And we use such a small
percentage of our lungs.
And I wish we all
could sit and meditate
in the base of the Rocky
Mountains in Montana,
but unfortunately we don't have
quite that Big Sky fresh air
around here.
So in atmospheres like
the Silicon Valley
I'm sure we have beautiful
meditation rooms,
but how do you remind
yourself, even when you're not
meditating, to breathe?
How do you just
incorporate that practice
into your daily motions?
LAMA TSOMO: Well, I am
addicted to my computer, too.
And I'll forget I'm on
a mountain top and all
of the glorious things,
and I'm sitting there
staring at the computer for
hours and hours every day.
I also am in a lot of meetings.
So you forget where you
are, at that point, right?
You're just paying
attention to the thing.
So I have this program which
I don't remember the name of,
but I bet there are
several of them.
And it just flashes
on your screen.
You can still see behind
it, and you can always
click it to dismiss it
quickly if you want to,
but it also is a moment to just
remind you to take a breath
and actually rest
your-- resting your eyes
and focusing them at
least 20 feet away
is really good for your eyes.
Keeps you from going
near-sighted, staring
at a screen all the time.
Your eyes aren't meant to
be focused on one distance
all the time.
So, for lots of
reasons, you can set it
for however timing you want,
if you want it every hour,
every half-hour, whatever it is.
That's a simple reminder.
Also, if you do happen to notice
that you're feeling anxious,
it's impossible physiologically
to be as anxious if you
take a big breath and exhale.
So we automatically sigh
sometimes when we're anxious,
and you could just do that
even when your body might not
have automatically done it.
But if you just know about
this, that's a moment
you can take a big breath.
And when you do meditate
you're not meant to, like,
force big breaths.
It's supposed to be
just quite natural.
And I find I tend to
savor in between in-breath
and out-breath, because
it's just so quiet
and still for that moment.
I kind of savor that.
So that's what I
would say about that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
Those are useful.
I wrote them down in
case any of you didn't.
You can come take
my notes later.
So if you would like
to guide us through.
LAMA TSOMO: Yeah.
So now we'll do a
more official guiding
through the practice
of Samatha meditation.
Shyine, in Tibetan.
And Shyine means
"peaceful abiding."
there are many different
kinds of meditation.
Everybody thinks there's-- or,
most people think there's just
one, but actually you can
come at this thing from many
directions.
Some are compassion
meditations, some
are-- actually there some
very athletic ones further
on down the road.
And some that clear away the
first static that we feel
when we sit down to meditate.
But the one I'm going to
share with you is Samatha.
So there isn't too much
more than I already
told you, actually.
It's very simple.
That doesn't mean
easy, but simple.
So one thing is posture.
And this is going to help you
to achieve the clear yet calm
state that we're going for.
What we aren't going
for is agitated,
nor are we going for sleepy.
And I don't know about you, but
when I haven't had enough sleep
and I drink too much coffee, I
can do both agitated and sleepy
at same time.
So we're not going for that.
We're going for clear and calm.
So there is an exercise for
that that only takes, like,
30 to 60 seconds.
It's in the book and there's
a demonstration of it
because there are some
movements on our website.
You can get to our
website from the handout.
It's Namchak.org.
N-A-M-C-H-A-K. Namchak.org.
Because you'll need
to see a video of that
to really be able to do it.
But it kind of jump starts
your Samatha practice.
So here's Samatha.
You sit with your back straight.
If you can do full Lotus
position, wonderful.
Tell your friends.
You should be proud you
can also sit cross-legged.
You can sit on a chair.
Any of that will do.
The main thing is
that you're sitting
with your hip joint bent.
And there's-- you know,
what happens with the prana,
the chi, is helped by that.
And then you need your back
straight because again,
your prana needs to flow
in a straight, open pathway
up your spine.
So you're sitting not
with a taut, rigid spine,
but supple and straight.
And it turns out that
hunching is actually
straining some muscles
more than you realize.
And a favorite thing is to
hunch and then have the head up,
and then go visit the
chiropractor for your neck.
So if you have your
vertebrae like a column,
it's actually less
strain on everything.
And you sit on your
sit bones, whether it's
a chair or cross-legged
or whatever it is.
If you are sitting on
the floor cross-legged,
it's important to have a
little bit of elevation.
Your rear needs to be on a
firm cushion and your knees
a little bit lower, and
it just really helps
to be able to sit straight
comfortably, very easily.
So that's important.
And the visualization
that I think
helps for me is imagining
that, through the back top
of my head, is a string that's
hanging from the ceiling.
So I'm like this marionette.
Very relaxed, very supple,
hanging from the ceiling.
And in our tradition we don't
close the eyes all the way,
we have them facing
down, sort of following
the line of the nose down.
And your mouth is
a little bit open.
You're going to actually breathe
mostly through your mouth.
The tip of your
tongue is touching
where the upper palate meets
the teeth, the upper teeth.
And once again, you just pay
attention to your breath.
Again, it's the
direct experience
of the movement of your belly or
the coolness across your mouth.
Thoughts will come and
go, and we let them.
You find you've been following
after a thought, good.
That's more awareness than
maybe you've had in years.
Noticing that.
And doing that bicep
curl for the brain,
bringing your mind
attention back to breath.
And breathing naturally.
That was a quick introduction.
And I'd like to follow
through with more right now,
so if anyone had
their devices on,
I'd like you to turn it off.
You won't need to
take any more notes.
And I invite you to take a
few minutes of real vacation.
So we'll do this
again, remembering
the marionette posture.
Eyes gazing down.
Tip of the tongue
where the upper palate
meets the upper teeth.
And settling our
attention on breath.
Again, if you've been following
after a thought, good.
You noticed.
Bring it back and settle
freshly back into Samatha.
The more times you notice
you've been making movies
in your mind, the more that
means you've been aware of it,
and the more times you can
freshly come back to Samatha.
If you find your
mind is too jumpy,
try to bring your
gaze a bit lower.
And if it's a bit sleepy,
raise your gaze just a bit.
Now I'd like you to take
a moment and reflect.
Ask yourself, how am
I feeling right now?
Adjectives, perhaps.
Images.
Whatever this is that you're
feeling, hopefully good,
I'd like you to savor it
for just a moment more
as I ring the bell.
And you listen to the sound
as it slowly fades away.
[BELL RINGS]
Thank you.